Smart投資教室上課了,大家好,我是金衣小姐姐璇依。
節目開始呢,我想先請大家思考一下,
我們當然知道說投資分兩條路,
一種叫做資產增值,另一種希望可以追求被動收入。
雖說你喜不喜歡這種就是不用一直盯盤,
可是定期有叮咚叮咚也是現金流進來的投資。
像我身邊有不少朋友,我除了投資股票之外,
也會配置一些債券或是債券型的ETF,
因為比起追求價差資產增值,
他們更在意的是被動收入
還有整個投資組合的穩定度
可是問題來了
想要用債券幫自己創造被動收入
該怎麼挑呢
今天我特別請到是
嶄新特步的創辦人
黃大展
大展哥來跟我們聊聊這個話題
先跟大家打聲招呼
大家好
各位Smart投資教室的朋友
我是大展
祝福看到這集朋友
都可以紅土大展
大展紅土
有梗
非常謝謝大展哥
其實大展哥比較少來Smart投資教室
所以我先幫大家來介紹一下
其實大展哥呢
他的這個在金融區的資歷
非常非常的豐富
他過去有帶過了野村投信
還有博瑞投信
累積了很多投資的心得之後
就成立了整星投股
然後同時呢
大家可能也看過他的文章哦
他在這個網絡上的筆名叫做小老闆
所以他有個粉專叫小老闆的二三世
所以大家看完之後呢
如果想覺得意猶未盡的話
都可以到小老闆的二三世
這個粉專來跟他討論
也可以追蹤起來
歡迎大家來找我
大展哥我剛剛一開始就破題了
就是有些人會想要透過
配置債券或者債券ETF
希望可以創造被動收入
但是因為老債券
真的是太不性感了
加上老實說
可能會喚醒一些人心中的傷痛
因為還有一群債挖
也就是過去2023 2024
買美債ETF的人
可能到現在都還沒有解套
所以他們對於債券投資
光這四個字就會覺得很有陰影
今天很需要你給大家明燈
讓大家重新認識
是債券投資的另一種選擇
我想的確是這樣子
那今天我們錄影時間
早上這個FED做了一個
2023年以來第一次升息的一個動作
那我想過去幾年
投資美債的朋友們一定是想說
美債進入一個降息循環
只是殊不知這個降息循環
走得相當的緩慢
那大家本來預期想藏到的
全都沒藏到
反而就是套住的人大有所在
那反而現在回到一個升息的循環
那這個時候呢
我就想就給投資朋友
有一個建議這樣子
那先提供一個數字
那根據彭博的資訊
其實截至今年的7月底
巴西的實質利率是9.6%
美國只有0.25%
如果你只有一筆錢
你拿去買巴西政府的公債
你的吸收是遠遠超過美國分債的
但是臺灣投資人都是喜歡買美債
主要就會覺得說美債安全穩定
不過其實美債的價格波動
不見得比新興市場來的小
這幾年我想大家都已經體驗過
對但確實因為剛剛大展哥提的例子是巴西
一般來說巴西我們有在投資圈比較久的人
就把它定位是在新興市場了
所以你的意思是說
比起美債你會認為說
也許可以考慮放在新興市場來領高息
你會透過剛剛的比較讓大家知道了
因為你說現在看起來
美債的波動度可能不亞於新興市場在
但是新興市場可以創造的吸收是更高的
但是尷尬的就是新興市場
這四個字也是很多人聽到就怕
在投資人定位真的很尷尬
尤其孩子被當成配菜
景氣好的時候確實還不錯
但是稍微有風吹草動就要跑了
對 您說的沒錯
其實新市場在長期就被大家當成是一個戰術性的配置
那我講今天跟觀眾朋友分享
現在情況已經不一樣
大家可以看到這張圖卡
其實這是從新興市場在市的資金流向
常年都是一個流出的情形
但是從2025年已經由富轉正
而且2025年流入新上
再次資金就有309億美元
那今年到5月底為止
又流入了244億美元
一年多的一個時間
總共流入了553億美元
所以錢已經開始在迴流了
只是臺灣投資人多半都還是不知道
所以其實從這個資金流向
我們就讓投資人明白了
我們很喜歡說
為什麼觀察全球資金流向很重要
因為我們會說
有一種錢叫做聰明錢
聰明錢
他們一旦就是眼光會比大家看得更精準
所以現在看得出來趨勢很明顯
錢開始會流到新興市場
但是重點還是想要問
就是追求報酬的同時
我們必須要可以承擔風險承擔波動
所以新興市場的風險比較高
這句話是對的嗎
我想其實新興市場的一個本身體質
當然一個變化
是常年都是在有不同的經濟循環
不同的狀況
那所以是要應對當時的經濟情形
去做一個決定
對那這個新興市場再次
但是經過整個循環
我還是想先分享個比較長期的
因為比較扭轉大家的一個印象
其實長期而言
新興市場債市的報酬
其實不亞於美債
如果你看這張圖
這個是過去20年來
主要固定收益資產的一個報酬表現
如果我們把起始點設為
20年前設為100
那截到今年3月
新興市場公司債
大約是300這樣的數字
就是20年代的三倍
好 那在複利的效果之下
新興市場強勢貨幣債
大概在293
也是接近300
甚至大家比較陌生
待會會比較多介紹的
新興市場本地債大概是218
那大家會覺得最安全的美國公債
反而只有175
甚至全球綜合型的一個債券是163
那反映在這些數字之下
其實債券市場本身就有個長期的複利效果
那剛剛提到這樣子的一個數字
就是新興市場債市
常年期大概只有6到7%
這樣子一個年化報酬率
而美國公債在這些升息循環的一個情況之下
這20年來年化其實有4個勝因
所以新興市場債券
它是有一定的一個金融加差
可以有比較高的利息收入
可以反而去彌補中間景氣循環
帶來一個波動
所以在這個情況之下
我們覺得大家對新興市場的印象
其實應該可以去扭轉說
它好像波動比較大
那甚至回到我們看到
比較基本面的部分
是 對
那大家會比較少關注
我想說這張圖卡
就是剛剛去分享一下是說
其實新興市場現在的體質
真的已經是不一樣
我們來看看這邊有4個指標
GDP的成長
財政赤字
經常漲和金融災害的餘額
還有債務佔GDP比重
所以看到
最右邊的新興市場
這一組裡面
經濟成長率
大概都在4%左右
這是持續之帶擴張的
財政赤字
都還可以控制到
3%到4%
甚至債務佔GDP的比率
現在大概才6成
甚至比很多的成熟國家
都還來得低
確實剛剛大展
已經透過實質的數據
然後我們常講
甚至會說
績效會說話
讓大家已經看到了
首先新市場基本面已經改善了
所以整個經濟結構狀況是更好的
這我想到一個譬喻
就是有點像就是說
我們以前印象中
那種比較容易與人麻煩的
叛逆青少年
現在當大人了對不對
因為估計新市場
就是真的是債券太多
通膨管不住
動不動就失控
然後匯率也一下就崩了
看起來從剛剛基本面的
四大指標觀察
現在它當大人成熟了
沒錯 我覺得是非常好的一個比率
那其實很多新興國家
其實就成熟了
他們建立了一個財政規則
也用制度去限制整個政府能借多少債
能花多少
那央行也從整個在空棚目標部分
也非常嚴格的這樣做控管
設定空棚目標之後
再回到整個設定調整利率
那貨幣政策的獨立性也強了很多
那還有一個數字非常有代表性
就是符合可以進入性 流動性 透明度標準
可以納到整個主要債券指數的一個新興國家
2003年只有31個
現在已經到67個國家了
所以市場變寬了也變深
OK 那現在投資人好奇的問題就是
我們剛剛已經從資金面
然後基本面
還有過往的績效面
看得出來確實它的機會是存在的
但投資人想知道的是
那在新興債市裡面
有這麼多的國家
錢要往哪裡放呢
OK 那我覺得可以從
實質利率的角度來看
簡單的講實質利率
就是明目利率去減掉通膨
就真正到你口袋底的這個報酬
可以想象如果你今天存在
現在銀行利率是20%好像很多
可是當地的通膨還超過20%
你根本其實還是一個負債手
對 好 那我們看看這張圖
在整個這張圖的最左邊
那個深藍色是成熟國家
中間綠色這個群組是新興市場
那右邊紫色是相對上比較發展
沒那麼成熟的邊境市場
那深色的這個柱狀圖
是呈現現在的實質利率
淺色的柱狀圖是呈現
未來12個月的原油估值
那我們看看左邊那一群
瑞典 美國 加拿大 英國 日本
實質利率都貼在零附近
甚至日本和紐西蘭還是負值
然後再看中間
巴西 土耳其 哥倫比亞 墨西哥 南非
甚至最右邊
剛剛說比較邊緣的新興市場
奈及利亞 烏克蘭 烏茲別克
埃及 喬治亞 哈薩克
這些實質利率都明顯高出一大段
更重要的是淺色的柱子
就是預估未來12個月
新興市場跟成熟國家實質利率的差距
還是會持續維持在高的
所以說我們用這個實質利率來看
確實顯現出來
現在相較於成熟國家
新興市場的實質利率是高的
而且真的也是比較誘人的
那如果我們用數字轉換的話
就講最早最早我們提到巴西好了
巴西現在的實質利率目前是9.61%
好那反觀呢
美國當然就是沒有那麼高了
那如果說用100萬
放在巴西的利率環境
簡單來說算個數學題
光是實質利率
它一年理論上
就有將近9萬6的空間
對 沒錯
投資在當地國家
真的是有蠻高的實率可以享受
那我們都不討論匯率的影響
理論上就是這樣
那當然對全球的大型資金來講的話
這就像看到一個
房客以未來越穩定的房經店命
這就是為什麼說
2025年開始有資金流落行情在時
好 我們現在可以理解了
其實就是吸引力導致資金迴流
就是玄義子提到的通明錢
那如果我們想要進一步選擇呢
其實新興市場債分兩種
那其實一開始大展哥就有提到
一個可能就是我們比較熟悉的
常聽到的美元計價的強勢貨幣債
另一種是當地貨幣計價的本地債
又來了要怎麼選擇呢
OK 好想
我覺得現在可以把焦點多關注在本地債
雖然說強勢貨幣債比較是美元為主
但是本地債現在的投資機會
其實也開始都在上升
因為新興國家的基本面都轉好
那它的匯率也都有一定的一個支撐
而且甚至都在升息的一個趨勢裡面
那我們這邊就用三個國家來做說
好
第一個是巴西
那這張圖卡呢
藍線是巴西幣對美元的匯率
往下代表升值
然後淺綠線呢
是巴西本地十年期
公債殖利率的一個水準
那這張圖我們可以看到
從2024年的12月
巴西幣一度貶到一美元
可以換六塊錢的巴西幣
那時候大家是都在說巴西完蛋了
可是到今年7月
大概一年半的一個時間
我可以看到巴西幣已經升值到
一美元只能換到五塊錢的巴西幣
其實用數學來換算
這個匯率就已經升值快兩成
那更何況還有殖利率是14%
所以你又拿殖利率又拿匯率
這是一個蠻高的一個數字
所以不但是賺到了匯率
那甚至也還是收到了
投資人很滿意的這樣的債息
那其實大家比較廣為人知
還有沒有其他的國家例子
也可以跟觀眾朋友分享
我想其實這樣的國家真的是很多
那我剛剛舉巴西可能大家會比較惡手
人家想好像就是一個欣賞的代名詞
那我現在舉一個例子
馬來西亞
我們鄰近亞洲的馬來西亞
對對對
其實馬來西亞也算是新興國家
那我想雖然是新興市場
但是它的財政相對的穩定
所以它10年期的公債殖利率只有3.7%左右
那5年來它的公債殖利率都在3%到4.6%
都比美債還來的低
對可是呢
它的整個馬來西亞貨幣呢
2024年的4月呢
最扁到1美元兌換4.78的
這樣子的馬來西亞幣
升到今年7月份
已經升到4塊錢
所以呢
升值大概有17%
那所以很明顯
它就是賺的就是這個匯差啦
你看它升值幅度是有17%
對 所以不同的新興國家
那個投資邏輯原則都是不同的
像馬來西亞
你會覺得說
那個利率水準
然後我們說新興國家
也沒有那麼高
但是這幾年
你還是可以賺到匯差的一個部分
好 那既然我們知道
巴西 馬來西亞
那我們光譜的另外一端
就是你講這種超級極端的
它的殖利率可能踢起來超級高
但它的匯率波動
可能也很刺激的
那我可以舉一個例子
我講奈及利亞
群一你應該沒有去過
對 那我知道在非洲
就是地圖上有看過
OK 大家也知道
它當地的殖利率
有到17%到20%
那是真正的高息
那既然貨幣從2024年
貶到最低的數字
到今年7月
這個波段已經回升
大概24%
所以非常明顯
它就是一個殖利率
跟匯率都是高波動的一個市場
這就是邊境市場的特性對不對
所以其實剛剛大展哥分享了三個市場
讓大家去理解
那我一路聽下來重點就是
這樣的本地貨幣債的報酬方式
其實是有三塊
第一個當然就是殖利率本身
也就是所謂的這個J券的票息
那第二個就是殖利率下降帶來的價差
另外還有匯兌收益
像我可能都已經有點投資經驗了
我都還是覺得說天啊太複雜了吧
而且有一些國家呢
他定理位置在哪邊
我們都不太確定
然後基本面也很難了解
更不用說去判斷
他的財政狀況
就算現在聽起來很心動
一般人要如何介入
是的 我想這就是要交給專家
只要你懂得把事情
交給有能力的人去做
像今天就是想跟大家分享
一個專家
就是威廉博萊
而且我知道這樣的專家
其實就是我們是操作
算是主動基金對不對
我們其實不是被動的追蹤指數
而是這樣的一個專家
他操作叫做主動基金
在經理人就不會只買進
像剛剛那樣子
耐吉利亞
就是高通線高波動的債券
而是會搭配的
因為其實大家投資債券
是想要領襲
也希望可以降低
整個投組的波動
所以說我覺得
透過這樣的專家
優點應該就是
在追求收益的同時
也可以來幫大家降低波動
因此不會犧牲
太多的總報酬
可是也想要請大展哥號
跟大家來介紹一下
這個專家威廉波來
他的厲害之處
還有它的背景
好 威廉布萊的總部
是在美國的芝加哥
公司創立到今
大概91年的時間
非常久
它的定位很清楚
主要是走的是
精品的一個路線
不是全產品線
那新市場在這個領域
就是它的強項
大家要知道說
追蹤全球市場的動態
不僅是需要整宏觀的視野
具體上還需要
更強大的一個交易平臺
以及深入當地市場的研究能力
那各位想象
一組人分佈在巴西
菲律賓 南非
跨時區的盯著這些市場
還有主權債
當地利率
貨幣
企業信用債
等各種領域的一個專家
這不只是研究能力的問題
還有規模的問題
所以我想會跟投資人去分享是說
資訊不對稱這件事情
你不用自己看
這邊有很多經理的專業
你是可以有效降低你的風險
那臺灣的投資人
要透過威廉博萊來投資星天市場
有什麼樣的工具
你覺得很適合在這個時間點
投資人可以介入
我們總代理威廉布萊的基金
現在在臺灣總共有四檔
除了一些票型基金以外
在新市場的債券的部分
我們除了去年引進的
以美元計價的新興市場
非都是等於債券基金
今年就特別想大家推薦的就是
威廉布萊新市場本地貨幣債券基金
所以等於就是有點像是
把新市場債的產品線給補齊了
無論是美元計價
或是本地的貨幣計價的
這樣的新市場基金
其實都有辦法可以讓大家來參與
對 本來美元計價
那一檔賺的是債券本身
那這一檔是在加上
當地貨幣跟當地利潤
而報酬來源更加完整
而且這一檔很特別是說
它不像很多產品
單純是用地區來分配
各國的一個普選程度
什麼意思啊
一般我們看債區
不就是用地區來劃分嗎
對 請看這張圖
在右邊紫色的部分
是市場上一般的分法
我們照地區分組
你是拉美一組
亞洲一組
歐非中東一組
然後再決定說
我們每個區域
要配多少的投資比
那再看看拉美那一組裡面
其實有同時有阿根廷 智利 墨西哥
那阿根廷是什麼體制呢
它常常在違約
智利又是什麼體制
其實它是single A的一個國家
所以阿根廷是容易違約
其實反而是比較不好的下面的
但是智利基本上它是優質的債券
是的 是的
所以這兩個國家的一個體制風險
是天差地遠
如果把它放在同一個框框裡面
這樣子去做分配
其實就會失聲
那同樣是在歐非中東那一組
你看到南非 波蘭跟烏克蘭
烏克蘭跟波蘭又是不一樣的一個風險
所以真的不能單純用地區來劃分
那威廉·波蘭他們劃分的做法是什麼呢
所以你就看到這個圖卡
左邊這一藍色這一塊
就是威廉·波蘭他不是用地區劃分
他是用Beta的屬性
那白話來講就是說
國家對市場的波動有多敏感
那我們看高Beta的部分
放上就是有阿根廷 烏克蘭 埃及
這些波動大
我剛剛提到了奈及利亞
波動大
但相對機會也大的
中β時放的是巴西
墨西哥
南非
在低β這一組
是放的是智利
波蘭跟菲律賓
體質相對比較穩健
這樣子的做法的好處
就是第一
它風險預算分配更有效率
它不會一小心
就把風險集中在
無量一個體質的國家
第二
如果做相對價值評估的時候
會可以是同等級的去做比較
判斷也更加更精準
第三如果市場環境變
你真的要整個調整
投資組的Beta的
負險程度
也可以比較快速的做調整
所以確實聽起來
是很聰明的分類方式
而且還兼顧到了
就是投資人
對於這個風險程度
還有整個投資組合的
這個Beta值的來控制
那配置比例的話
又是多少
那看這張表
這檔基金
在風險預算
那個配置的一個架構
那在高Beta這個部分
也是風險最高
最刺激的部分
單一國家的主動曝險程度
也只能佔大概0.25%到0.75%
就看整個投資團隊的研究的信心度多高
最多也就是放到1.5%
那反而來看低波動這個群組
體質比較穩的這部分
標準狀況是可以看到放到0.75%到1.5%
在高強度的信心可以就放到2.5%
這樣子的一個跟指標上的一個差距
所以這個主動積極的程度
跟你你今天凸顯的一個程度
都可以都帶去做調整
所以其實最大的優點
就是因為它是一個主動基金
是由這個經理人
還有整個同學團隊
會去調配
然後根據每一個國家的基本面
還有Beta值的狀況
以及剛剛這個限定的
限制範圍之內
讓整個投組的狀態
是可以有機會
創造最大的總報酬
但是可以把風險
在可控的範圍之內
非常謝謝大展哥
今天的分享
讓我們今天真的知道了
現在新興市場的體質
已經改變了
無論是它的經濟成長
財政幾率
還有整個通膨的管理
都跟過去不一樣了
像璇玉剛剛說的
過去的叛逆青少年
現在當大人了
所以不但是基本面的改善
市值利率
透過數字圖表
剛剛都發現了
明顯是高於成熟國家的狀況之下
如果說你對於這樣的借券投資
或是這樣的借券主動基金
尤其是在新興市場的部分
你好奇的話
大家也可以多加來留意
新興市場在市的投資機會
Smart投資教室
我們下回再見
拜拜
投資一定有風險
基金投資有賺有賠
申購前應享月公開說明書和投資人須知